welcome back to GQ rules I'm Adam
Rapoport this is Domenico Vacca who's
joining us again Thank You Domenico
thank you thank you for having me
last time we talked scars this time the
talking shoes though our shoot brown
shoes
I have never in my life worn Brown shoes
too bad who had I told you that last
time I thought I wanted wore black shoes
and you said to me I said only for
wedding and funerals you know and you
see Italian guys in Italy they almost
always have brown dress shoes on the
street they look impeccable what's the
secret
we love shoes we have men's right now
them into shoes more than women having
two shoes being a little bit more
creative in the way you dress while I do
like black shoes you kind of look like
you work for the FBI or something I work
for the government you're very just
straight-laced very conservative brown
shoes except they've got a little more
attitude a little more character these
are beautiful all the way down to the
darker lace-up so what I love about this
shoe for instance it's kind of light
there it's a little darker here
absolutely has that much more handmade
feel instead of just all factory stamped
out that gives you some perspective it
gives you some depth it's like a
painting at the end of the day and
always back to art with your telly okay
that's it
the secret is that actually is a little
bit easier to polish this shoe that not
for example black shoes you know most of
the brown shoes you're gonna really
polish with a neutral color and polish
let's talk suits a navy suit a grey suit
you should start with a grey suit she's
very easy to match the belt with the
shoes because the ruling rest of the
belt with like some black sea wood
branches that's a definite bit more of a
thick Exile yeah definitely your anyway
of Exile yeah I probably start with
something a little darker I do issues
there from this I'm sort of that time
the first step should be a
chocolate-brown in terms of belt in
terms of shoes is gray you can see for
example in the suede shoes they go as
well with everything start off with more
chocolate brown consider wearing it with
the grey suit to start off with polish
and well clear polish doesn't have to be
a brown polish and wearing with
confidence and be proud absolutely we'll
have a lot of fun
I'm Adam rapport that's Domenico Vacca
thanks for watching GQ rules tune in
tomorrow for another essential style tip
[Music]